- Welcome back, y'all.
Every year at this time,
families and friends
across the nation get
together to enjoy holiday...
(audience whoops)
Yeah!
They enjoy holiday
meals, Christmas stories.
Not me. I love Christmas all year long.
What do?
- Boo!
- Oh!
Hi!
(Grinch laughs)
Hi, Grinch.
- Yeah!
(audience cheers)
- Hello! What are you doing here?
- Well, you know, I'm just admiring all
of your wonderful Christmas decorations
and plotting which ones to steal.
I mean, planning, which ideas to steal.
- Oh, exactly.
(Grinch chuckles)
- For my own very...
This is awkward.
My own holiday celebration extravaganza.
- Okay.
- Sure, we'll go with that.
- Okay. (laughs)
(audience cheers)
- Okay. Okay.
So you're finally, like,
coming around on Christmas.
This is nice.
- Don't be ridiculous.
- What?
- All that singing, all that merry-making,
all of that roast
beasting, it makes me sick.
(audience giggles)
- All right.
(audience chuckles)
Well, you know, the way
you were creeping up on me,
it reminds me of a game that
we usually play on this show.
I was...
You wanna maybe play a game?
You wanna play?
- No, it sounds way too wholesome.
I'll pass, thank you.
(audience laughs)
- Well, we can make it interesting
and put something on the line.
We can, you know.
(audience agrees)
If you're afraid of losing, it's fine.
- I see you, Kelly Clarkson.
Clarky.
I see you, okay.
You like a little friendly
competition as much as I do.
- Yes.
(Grinch chuckles)
- Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'm in.
- All right, all right.
It's time for...
(audience cheers)
I'm excited about this...
A Grinch round of:
♪ What's creeping up on me ♪
(audience cheers)
- Wow.
- She can be tough.
Watch out for that one.
- Hoo!
(Kelly laughing)
- Here's how it works.
So the Grinch will start
with his back to the screen.
I'll give him clues about
what's creeping up behind him
without saying the name of the thing.
And then we're gonna switch sides,
and The Grinch will give me clues.
All the clues are based around Grinchmas,
which is part of the holiday celebrations
at Universal Studios Hollywood.
Also Universal Orlando Resorts.
And we can pass, if one is
too hard, you can say pass.
If we correctly guess 10, 10 things total,
then in two rounds, then the Grinch...
And, you know, we'll give everyone
in our audience a wonderful
Christmas present.
(audience cheers)
- Hey, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa.
Pump the breaks, kid.
Let's call it a um, a...
Grinchmas present.
I'm in.
- All right. All right.
A Grinchmas present.
Okay, cool.
And if we fail at the game,
well, Christmas is canceled,
so let's...
(audience sighs)
- Yes! Finally, this whole
Christmas season outta here!
(Grinch laughing)
- I can, I can sense that.
Okay, okay. Are you ready?
So you're gonna, your
back's gonna be here,
and I'm gonna be over here.
- Okay, let me stretch.
- Yeah. Okay.
Get ready.
(Grinch farts)
- Excuse me.
- Yeah.
Oh! (chuckles)
- It's the eggnog.
- You know what?
It's worth it.
Okay, let's do it.
Okay. Oh, this is, oh, it's,
it's something you love.
Little family member of yours.
A little family member who's
a traveler and sometimes...
- Max?
- Yes!
(bell rings)
♪ I did it ♪
- Oh!
- Oh, wait, wait.
This is the little girl who
found you one Christmas night.
- That hideodorous creature Cindy Lou Who?
- Yes! Yes!
Okay, okay, okay.
So this is, oh pass.
Can't remember his name.
Pass. It's the mayor though, of Whoville
- Augustus?
- Oh! There you go.
Yes! Yeah.
Yes, yes.
I was like, for a minute,
blanked on his name.
I blanked on his name.
Okay. Okay.
So these are the people
that live in Whoville.
- The Whos? (chuckles)
- The Whos! There you go.
There you go.
(bell rings)
- Right on the nose.
Someone stretched out for that one.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Okay. So, oh, this is a
place you go and it's so fun
and you ride roller coasters
and you get to go to
Grinchmas and you get to...
(Grinch gasps)
- Universal Studios Hollywood!
- Yeah!
(bell rings)
- Okay, okay!
(jingle music plays)
- Oh!
Oh, we switch.
Okay, okay times up.
- [Grinch] Oh, times up.
- Times up.
Time's up, okay. We switch.
I dunno where my thing, I'm gonna go here.
Wait, what?
- Where'd you go?
- [Kelly] You're the wrong way.
- Oh, wrong way.
- Okay. We got five, right?
So we need five more.
- [Grinch] Sure.
- [Kelly] Are you ready?
- Okay, five more.
- Okay, switch sides. Let's do this.
Okay. The Grinch is giving clues now.
So let's start the clock and go.
- Okay. It's a, you take a knife
and you stab a carcass
over and over again.
- Turkey!
- Sure.
- Whoo!
(bell rings)
- Ah, it's so cute.
It makes me wanna fill a diaper.
Okay so...
- Baby!
- Hot thing of...
It's a hot thing of something
and it's got the little...
- Hot cocoa!
- That's the one.
(bell rings)
- Yeah!
- That was good.
Oh, these dumb dumbs stand
out there and they're like...
(imitates carolers)
- Carolers!
- Yeah.
(bell rings)
- I love caroling!
- This is fun.
(Grinch grunts)
All right.
Ooh, I love sticking moths on these.
And they evaporate right over the hearth.
- What?
- You put your foot in it.
- A stocking!
- There you go!
(bell rings)
- Okay.
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh, I need to see my movie.
Ah, he's a big fat guy that
flies all way like this...
- Santa!
- That's the one!
(bell dings)
(Kelly screams)
- We did it!
(horn blows)
(audience cheering)
(Grinch giggles)
- Wait, wait, wait.
Is Christmas canceled?
- No, you have to save Christmas.
- Dang it.
(Kelly giggles)
- So that means the Grinch
has a gift for everyone here.
That's so kind.
Would you like to tell
them about it or should I?
- No, you tell 'em
because I don't wanna see their merriment.
It's too much too soon.
(Kelly chuckles)
- Okay. The biggest, loudest
awesome holiday celebrations
of the season are back at
Universal Studios Hollywood
and Universal Orlando Resort
with both destinations
hosting amazing festivities that are fun
for the whole family, which he loves,
and everybody has even
more reason to be merry.
- [Grinch] Yeah.
- Because you're all getting
two one-day general admission tickets
to experience the festivities
of Grinchmas this year...
(audience cheering and applauding)
You're going to be able
to enjoy the cheerful
Grinchmas Whovillation
which is an annual family tradition
for a wholiday fun.
See what I did there?
With the Grinch, his faithful
dog, Max and the Whos.
- You can come and meet me and Max,
in a special photo opportunity.
(Kelly and The Grinch laugh)
- Plus you're gonna marvel in amazement
at the Grinchmas tree decorated
with hundreds of ornaments
and thousands of LED lights,
including a spectacular
tree lighting ceremony
and the chance to hear a live retelling
of The Grinch's story along
with the Whoville Whos
bringing joy and merriment to all.
That was very generous.
- I'm surprised we can afford it.
(The Grinch and Kelly laugh)
So many feelings.
My heart.
It's just, I have to, I have to have got,
I gotta go...
Max!
I need a hug.
- Give it up for The Grinch everybody!
(audience cheering and applauding)
All right.
The holiday celebrations at
Universal Studios Hollywood
and Universal Orlando Resort run daily
through Sunday, January 1st .
It's awesome. Go with your family.
Have a good time. Go with friends.
Merry Grinchmas, everybody.